I love driving the open road and I heard
Alberta is amazing for that driving into
the Rockies in a convertible and feeling
the fresh air surrounded by incredible
mountains it just really inspired me to
experience as much as I possibly could a
canoe Lake Lewis in the early morning
the color of the water was just unreal
an awesome way to take in all the nature
at once I've never been brought climbing
before so I had a local guy come and
teach me then we're gonna go right up
here I was really scared because I have
this irrational fear of heights but as
soon as I got up there I was completely
overtaken by the beauty of everything
surrounding it my eyes but anything more
beautiful things have gotten to do Jing
downs are gonna be the funnest thing
that
we have to make it happen right
I met up with my buddy Matt who lives in
the area and he suggested a really cool
way to experience the Rockies is to ride
up in a gondola whitethorn bistro is on
the top of the mountain and it's the
best place to take in the expansive
views they have a healthy hiking tour
that would be absolutely insane okay
yeah that's amazing
the helicopters took me to the highest
peak in the area
it was completely different it felt like
I was on the moon I can't really explain
the emotional experience of being in
such a fast place
you just have this sense of connectivity
to nature and it's an amazing feeling